AMERICAN LEADER.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS JOINS US FROM THE
NORTH LAWN WITHOUT STORY.
YOU'D EVENING, JOHN.
>> BRET, GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
THE PRESIDENT BEGAN HIS DAY
MEETING WITH A MAN WHO WILL BE
THE NEXT KING OF SAUDI ARABIA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOVELING OFF
ALL THE SHINY MILITARY HARDWARE
THAT THE SAUDIS WILL BE BUYING.
IT WAS RUSSIA THAT QUICKLY ROSE
TO THE TOP OF THE NEWS.
MEETING IN THE OVAL OFFICE WITH
THE SAUDI CROWN PRINCE MOHAMMED
BIN SALMAN, PRESIDENT TRUMP
REVEALED A PLAN TO MEET WITH
RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> WE WILL PROBABLY GET TOGETHER
IN THE NOT-TOO-DISTANT FUTURE,
SO THAT WE CAN DISCUSS ARMS, WE
CAN DISCUSS THE ARMS RACE.
>> TALK OF THE MEETING CAME
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED
PUTIN TO CONGRATULATE HIM ON HIS
LATEST ELECTION VICTORY.
A CALL DURING WHICH THE
PRESIDENT MENTIONED NOTHING
ABOUT ELECTION MEDDLING OR THE
NERVE AGENT POISONING OF A
FORMER RUSSIAN SPY IN BRITAIN.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT CAME UP ON
THE SPECIFIC BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE SPOKEN EXTENSIVELY
ABOUT.
>> IS THE RECENT POISONING IN
THE UNITED KINGDOM COME UP IN
THE CALL?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WAS
DISCUSSED.
>> ARIZONA SENATOR JOHN McCAIN
CHASTISED THE PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALL, AND A STATEMENT SAYING, AN
AMERICAN PRESIDENT DOES NOT READ
THE FREE WORLD BY CONGRATULATING
DICTATORS ON WINNING SHAM
ELECTIONS."
EVEN THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
GAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP A
RHETORICAL BACK OF THE HAND.
>> WHEN I LOOK AT A RUSSIA
ELECTION, WHAT I SEE IS A LACK
OF CREDIBILITY, CALLING HIM OR
DON'T HAVE BEEN HIGH ON MY LIST.
>> THE CONGRATULATORY PHONE CALL
ASIDE, THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY
INSISTED IT IS GETTING TOUGH
WITH RUSSIA.
BUT SAID IT DOESN'T HAVE MUCH
CONTROL OVER WHO GETS ELECTED IN
RUSSIA OR HOW.
>> WE DON'T GET TO DICTATE HOW
OTHER COUNTRIES OPERATE.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT PUTIN
HAS BEEN ELECTED IN THEIR
COUNTRY.
>> THE INVESTIGATION INTO
RUSSIAN METAL AND GOT ANOTHER
NEWS BUMP TODAY AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP ADDED FORMER
U.S. ATTORNEY JOE     GO TO JOHN
ABOUT TO HIS LEGAL TEAM.
HE BELIEVES THERE WAS A
CONSPIRACY AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
OF THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE
FBI.
>> THERE WAS A BRAZEN PLOT TO
ILLEGALLY EXONERATE
HILLARY CLINTON AND IF SHE
DIDN'T WIN THE ELECTION, TO THEN
FRAME DONALD TRUMP WITH A
FALSELY CREATED CRIME.
>> IN THE WAKE OF ANDREW
McCABE'S FIRING FROM THE FBI,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT ON A
TWITTER RANT AGAINST THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, REPEATEDLY
CALLING IT A WITCH HUNT,
TWEETING AT MAD AT SHOULD NEVER
HAVE BEEN STARTED.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE AGAIN IS
DATED THE PRESIDENT IS NAYLOR
THINKING ABOUT NOR HAS PLANS TO
FIRE MUELLER.
MITCH McCONNELL GAVE MUELLER A
BIG THUMBS UP TODAY.
>> I THINK YOU WILL HAVE GREAT
WETTABILITY WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, WHEN HE REACHES THE
CONCLUSION OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO VENTED
HIS FRUSTRATION AT SANCTUARY
CITIES TODAY, CONVENING A GROUP
OF LIKE-MINDED LAWMAKERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS, VOWING A
CRACKDOWN ON CITIES HE SAYS ARE
VIOLATING FEDERAL LAW.
>> SANCTUARY CITIES ARE
DANGEROUS, AND WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE CARE OF THE PROBLEM.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WAVED A
SCOLDING FINGER AT HER RANT
TODAY, REMINDING THAT THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL IS UP FOR
ANOTHER SANCTIONS WAIVER
DECISION.
THE LAST TIME THE PRESIDENT
SIGNED A WAIVER, HE INDICATED HE
WASN'T GOING TO KEEP DOING THAT,
FROM NOW UNTIL THE TIME IS OVER.
BUT THE PRESIDENT SAYING TODAY,
WHEN HE WAS ASKED WHAT HE WAS
GOING TO DO ABOUT IRAN, SAID,